mri fancy glasses and my my original
for a future university and together
with my team who burn tobias project
tracking of plastics in arscene
and winter is in hell potion can
smooff stuff from
this is that can be anything from bacteria
of fish or ld
toe plastic  we more important three
minutes nowhere the placement is now
because your stand is impact on the
plastic to a real life is the cause
joosje is still the cm everywhere you he
ria are iocean with beer hi buyer at
first i think about the corys
nrs  of the ocean which for lower body
first and plastic in the ocean de span
the more harmful
in the arm ear and to us direction yard
juno like anyone else having that place
i in the ocean is an atrocity it inc
baby serbia schöndorff is what to the
other hand when who the media so
image lacks information thicker and it
seems is he fell so my role
provider pray of more context of what
brierly this plastic in the ocean
desserts
so becomes mutates e  n zoey setup media
press campaign to the bank
some of the bigger smit de guard there
construction sites video show for jump oil
you that there
highlands of plastic floating summer and
middle of the realization box
yes there splash me again what is another
island is a bit gloomy  where you can go to
so becomes now because the to do in her
audience in gaming camping is zooming
barry's clear what works harder and where
do i place in the ocean what is become
mino
and en specially what the earth teams
have still don't know
weekend  surround sets academics and
write your review papers and of course
this important
with willy for science to make an impact
to society you far and games
we not a gates republic and act is
out shop where
hi-hat liesbeth most of the excitement
and rewards and  and the energy of being
en academic like a ja
[Music]